We're on problem 13.
And they say if 4x is equal to
6u, which is equal to 5v,
which is equal to 7w, all of
which is greater than 0, which
of the following is true.
So they're essentially wanting
you to order w to-- they want
you to order these terms in
order from least to greatest.
So one thing I'm going to do,
let me order these terms, the
coefficients from least to
greatest. That's the same
thing as 4x is equal to 5v,
which is equal to 6u, which is
equal to 7w.
They're all greater than 0.
So what's going to be
greater, x or w?
So if I have 4 of something
and that equals 7 of this
thing, this is going to be
the smallest, right?
Think of it this way.
If x was 7, then w would be 4.
Try that out.
If x was 7 and this term would
be 28, the w would be 4.
So w is the smallest. And by
that same principle, u is
going to be next.
So w is less than u, which
is less than v, which
is less than x.
And it's just on the principle,
if it takes me 7 of
something to make up the 4 of
something else, this thing has
to be bigger because I
need fewer of it to
make 7 of this thing.
And by the same logic u is less
than v, right, because
you need 6 of that thing
to make one of v.
I mean if you really wanted to
kind of try it out you could
divide all of these by 4 and
you'd get x is equal to 5/4v,
which is equal to 6/4u, which
is equal to 7/4w.
All of these terms are
greater than 1.
So x is more than
all of these.
And you could do it for all of
these and you would see that
same order.
That whichever one has the
highest coefficient is going
to be the smallest number, and
then the next smallest is
going to be u, then v, then x.
So let's see what choice that
is. w is less than u, which is
less than u, which
is less than x.
That's choice D.
Problem 14.
Let the function h be defined by
h of t is equal to 2 times
t cubed minus 3.
When h of t is equal to minus
60, so h of t is equal to
minus 60, what is 2 minus 3t?
What is 2 minus 3t.
So let's see what
we can do here.
2 minus 3t.
So h of t is equal to minus 60,
so minus 60 is equal to 2
times t cubed minus 3.
Fair enough.
And then divide both
sides by 2.
I'm just trying to see where
I can go with this.
Divide both sides by 2.
So you get minus 30 is equal
to t cubed minus 3.
Add 3 to both sides you get
minus 27 is equal to t cubed.
This is pretty straightforward.
Something to the third power
is equal to minus 27.
Well what's the cubed
root of 27?
It's 3.
So the cubed root of minus
27 is minus 3.
So t is equal to minus 3.
And you could try that out.
What's minus 3 to
the third power?
Minus 3 times minus 3 is 9 times
minus 3 is minus 27.
So when h of t is minus 60,
t is equal to minus 3.
And so what is 2 minus 3t, which
is what they asked us
originally?
It's going to be 2 minus
3 times minus 3.
So it's 2 minus minus 9 or 2
plus 9, which is equal to 11.
And that is choice B.
Next problem.
I'll switch colors.
Where was I?
My brain is fried from doing all
of these SAT problems. But
I figure I do it once an it'll
be there forever for students
for the rest of eternity to
learn SAT problems and compete
with my future children and
they'll be [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Problem 15.
If x is divisible by 3 and y
is divisible by 5, which of
the following must be
divisible by 15?
So x divisible by 3, so x is a
multiple of 3-- you can view
it that way.
y is the divisible by 5.
Which of the following must
also be divisible by 15?
Do you know how I'm
going to do it?
I'm going to say look, you could
write x is equal to 3k
where k is some integer.
We don't know what multiple x
is of 3, but we know 3 times
some integer, k,
is equal to x.
And similarly, you could say y
is equal to 5, I don't know,
5m where you could say
some integer m times
5 is equal to y.
Because we know that 5 times
something's equal to y.
That's what divisible means.
So let's look at the choices.
1.
They want to know which
are the ones that are
divisible by 15.
So choice 1 is x times y.
Well x times y is the same
thing as 3k times 5m.
And that's the same
thing as 15km.
So xy is the same thing as 15
times a product of integers,
and the product of two integers
is going to be an
integer, right?
So this is definitely
divisible by 15.
So choice 1 is divisible
by 15.
Problem 2.
3x plus 5y.
So we could do the same thing.
x is 3k, so that's 3 times 3k
plus 5y plus 5 times 5m.
That equals 9k plus 25m.
This isn't necessarily
divisible by 15.
I mean what if k and
m are both 1?
Then you get 34 and-- this
is not divisible by 15.
Choice 3.
5x plus 3y.
Doing the same thing.
That equals 5 times 3k,
right, this is x.
5 times 3k plus 3 times 5m.
And this equals 15k plus 15m.
An you can factor out the 15.
That's 15 times k plus m.
And once again, so this thing is
equal to 15 times k plus m.
k plus m is going to
be some integer.
We said k and m are
both integers.
So this term right here is
definitely divisible by 15.
So one and three
are our answer.
And that is choice D.
And you know, if you didn't want
to do this fancy stuff
where you say it's multiplying
by some integer,
et cetera, et cetera.
Just x is divisible by 3, y is
divisible by 5, well let's
just say x is equal to 3
and y is equal to 5 and
then try them out.
Then xy is going to be 15,
which is, of course,
divisible by 15.
This would be, let's see, 3
times 3 plus 5 times 5, this
would be 34.
Not divisible by 15.
And then the final one, 3 times
5 is 15 plus 3 times 5
is 15, this would be 30, which
is divisible by 15.
So that would have been the
quick and dirty, not
necessarily the most
mathematically rigorous way of
doing it, but it would have
gotten you the right answer.
And that really is what matters,
I guess, on the SAT.
That would have been the quick
and dirty solution.
Let me see if I can
draw this thing.
One line like that.
One line something like that.
And what do they tell
us about this?
I'll use yellow.
They tell us that this angle
right here is 115 degrees.
This is line l.
This is z degrees.
Line m, line n, and
this is y degrees.
Looks like we're going to have
to play the angle game here.
This is y degrees.
In the figure above
what is y plus z?
So when I play the angle game
I just try to figure out as
many sides as I can.
So if this is 115 what
is this going to be?
Well 115 plus this
supplementary, right?
So these are going to add up to
be 180, so this is going to
be 180 minus 115.
What's 80 minus 15?
It's 65, right, because
80 minus 10 is 70.
So this is 65 degrees.
And I just said that because
this angle plus
this has to be 180.
Now what is this angle
right here?
This angle right here is going
to be 180 minus y for the same
reason because it's
supplementary to y.
This angle here, same reason,
it's going to be 180 minus z.
And we know that this angle
plus this angle plus this
angle has to add up to 180.
So 65 plus 180 minus y plus 180
minus z is equal to 180.
Let's see, so that's-- you could
subtract 180 from both
sides, you get a 0 here.
What's 65 plus 180?
65 plus 180 is 245 minus y
minus z, is equal to 0.
Add y and z to both sides, you
get 245 is equal to y plus z.
And that is choice E.
See you in the next video.